there's no blame  lebron how have you seen  frank operate the last couple games  maybe in the last week is there's  obviously been  more reports that you know he  he could be his job could be in jeopardy  listen i'm not in a i'm not in a bit i'm  not in that business of uh  pointy fingers or or pointing blame or  trying to uh put a quote at the end or  at the start of somebody's uh  that's someone's commentator of what  they feel you know our coaching staff or  or frank is or where russ is or where  i'm at or 80  um if it's not positive for me i'm  i'm cool it's not it's not my it's not  my lane  i'm not i'm not a negative person  so if you got something  which i probably don't know